[Music]
hello good afternoon and welcome to
sidetrack your sci-fi tv a movie channel
that's my little intro i like and today
i am i was always on a sunday because
it's super sci-fi sunday uh
joined by the resident american himself
stormy bear how are you stormy well i'm
not drunk it's fourth of july weekend
it's a miracle
it's uh it's my wife's birthday fourth
of july so and she says it's nice that
the americans always have a nice little
party for me on her birthday oh yes we
set [ __ ] on fire and blow our fingers
off exactly i've been it's all very
rushed today because i've been away and
i've still got the wristband i can't get
it off something i've walked in the door
run upstairs gone live oh my god oh my
god oh my god
so yeah panic stations ah i was nearly
late but we made it just about right so
today we are going to be talking about
great space battles and normally we will
talk about what we've been watching but
how do you fancy just do that at the end
stormy and we'll instead talk about
we'll just get straight into the topic
right so
great space battles somebody that um i
trying to get this off somebody that i
um one of our subscribers calls it um
uh space
or or or spaceship porn yeah
that's that's great that's what i want
i love
jazz
oh yeah i love a good space battle in a
sci-fi movie or a tv show
um
hello and happy sunday shelley
hello
yeah um
straight in andy this is my hill and
i'll dine at one of the greatest space
battles the fan made our birth versus
deck chair
fair enough uh right so
um for me
the daddy
of the great space battle in sci-fi and
you're probably gonna go what is um
i don't know if you should you shouldn't
go that high pitched when you go what
but i do so leave me alone
um
is the wrath of khan
star trek
watched it again researching something
that whole movie it's not coming off
um that whole movie i love how
um i'm going to talk about what what
nurse me about um
some space battles in a in a bit when we
get to that bit but um
that movie it's
there's tension there's like it's like a
game of chess you know that they're
trying to outsmart each other and i love
it where he says about how it's um oh
he's he's a very clever man and his
tactics are good but he's thinking two
dimensionally in 2d
yeah so all they do is go oh we'll just
go down a bit then and then come back up
again that's the tactic for you know
it's like it's but i liked i liked how
it was like the tension the chest
between the two you know between khan
and kirk and
so for me that's the daddy of the space
battles you know
what do you think what what
okay so the daddy of space battles
that mine's going to be controversial i
think
go on because it was not really this is
in star trek
it was not really well represented
in any one medium
but it was also kind of everywhere and
that's the battle for uh wolf three five
nine
uh
we see a good chunk of it uh
season one episode one of uh
deep space nine of course there's that
whole theme of lucocious
in uh next generation
uh there was the battle of three five
nine pops up in the mirror universe
it was been it's been mentioned numerous
books now it was even mentioned in the
doctor who
star trek
next generation crossover comic books
yeah you know and it you see so many
bits and pieces of the battle
in different media and when you kind of
absorb
the whole thing
it was really epic but it's not ever
been because of budgetary constraints i
mean it was one hell of a throw down
between one board cube and what
36 30 something like that that was yeah
i mean you know when the klingons were
on their way the romulans are on the way
i mean it was just
and it was a beat down
for federation romney and star empire
and the klingon empire is a bit of a
quiz question for anybody in the uh
audience who answers what vessel
survived the battle of wolf 359 now i've
got to try to remember because that was
a quiz question for us and when we did
the when we did the side track question
but see anybody get in there tell us
what ship survived the battle of three
five nights well it wasn't the cerritos
because
we saw the cerritos in the opening going
up to a borg
battle but there were three cubes not
one so therefore it wasn't worth three
and it was there was romulan vessels
present as well wasn't it so that's a
battle you don't know about right right
yeah yeah but um yeah i think that would
have been very cool if we'd have got to
see it which way i suppose we did get to
see in the parts of it at least in the
opening sequence of ds9 now ds9 if
you're talking about a tv series that
has
um
the the the that you know from a tv
point of view deep space nine had some
great batteries you know the the the the
whole conv it opened with a great battle
scene at the battle of all three five
nights and i mean that the opening
episode the opening five minutes of deep
space nine blew my freaking mind i mean
you know when
when when you see avery books for brooks
uh portraying uh cisco
you know looking at his wife's face at
the very last time and being torn away
from her in the disintegrating starship
it is just i just watched it a few
minutes ago again just for this show and
it's like
that [ __ ] can act i mean because i
just teared up he's like god you're
looking at her face the last time
you know and you're focusing on that
somebody else has to toe your son away i
mean it was you know
i think you know the the
this is really off topic but uh yes deep
space nine is my favorite trek series
and i think it's more of a story between
about what a good father is
yeah you know
best portrayal of
a father-son dynamic i think ever in
regardless of genre ever you know
yeah we had a chat
i can't remember i think it might be you
and spence was it because what's your
favorite star trek but what's the best
star trek
and for me my favorite star trek is tng
because that's right
introduced me to it my favorite
characters picard
but the best star trek was deep space
nine
yeah not the first two or three series
the two first two or three series like
all track was a bit more but as soon as
the defiant came into it
yeah damn that was good track
and it was exciting it was it was it was
super chew juice
so
you know bad guys starboard bow destroy
them and it was like there was none of
this um oh let's try to talk to it well
i suppose they did try to talk to their
own but as soon as the pegasus was
destroyed they were like now let's kill
them so now it was uh brilliant and
for me some of the best episodes from
the episode went in
i didn't know what it was called but
it's gone from you know when cisco's
talking into the camera because um he's
doing the and then at the end of the
episode he computer delete log something
yeah
that was a ridiculously powerful episode
um you know i mean and and they launched
a thousand memes
but um some of the space battles there
were
uh i mean if you if you are talking
about space porn or or battleship oh man
it was good
you know it was just like um because one
of my gripes with um
space battles even a star trek whatever
is there not long enough i want i want a
really good you know i want like a 20
minutes baseball yeah or i want an
entire film that's just you know xfinity
khan right kind of was one long space
battle in a way because you mean it
started quite early on was the first
attack then the enterprise was like you
know hiding around and moon while
they're down on the genesis and then
they thought you know that was just
started i want to film i want more films
like that
um which we don't get to see they tend
to be even like star trek nemesis is
probably one of the longest space
battles we've seen in a star trek movie
for a while
and you know not a great movie but a
pretty good space battle and but even
that was was not that long i think it's
like 12 minutes or something um
star wars
great space battles
i have a star wars selection
uh this is a star wars episode three the
battle of coruscant it opens up in the
battle
you know you have anakin and obi-wan
flying these uh fighters
trying to rescue palpatine
and there was
there was just a lot
i mean in terms of space battles if you
if you watch it frame by frame there's
all sorts of [ __ ] going on in the
background you know you see you know
engagement
from one side to the other
you know
there's like these huge little battles
going on it's in the background though
you know and then there's because the
main story lines in anakin and and
obi-wan trying to get to the pout to get
to palpatine
but though if you look at it there's
just so much [ __ ] going on in the
background you know as they're trying to
make their way forward it's insane
i mean it must have taken i mean most of
the budget had to be in that
yeah because it was great i mean it
hadn't been thousands of ships
yeah and that's one of the things i love
about the
um
when he went back and actually redid the
the original three before the new films
came out and he added loads of fighters
and he added loads of you know ucgi
really effectively
really beefed up the battle scene george
lucas are really beefed up the battle
scenes from the original three um you
know the the initial attack on
um you know the first death star in a
new hope
is
you know in the original maybe it wasn't
as grand as he wanted but in the in the
in the
you know the reimagining the the the the
what's it called the digitally
remastered version that was a hell of a
space battle and again it was even
though we can go into the logic of
a torpedo getting sucked apparently into
events that blows hot air out um
space wizards um you know this like it's
a hell of a battle and the way it was
designed going down the the
the um you know the
canyon whatever you want to call it
right man it was the tension that sort
of one a good space battle should have
did you
did you know and i just learned about
this recently and i thought it was in a
different state but
there's a canyon called star wars canyon
here in california
that you can that
fighter jets out of uh edwards air force
base and other places in the southwest
they go and practice in this [ __ ]
canyon
you know and i think it's been depicted
in a bunch of movies uh independence day
comes to mind but you can actually fly
it yourself if you got an airplane or
you can
they've got the the at a mojave
spaceport you can
somebody in an f4
fighter from vietnam will take you
through it screaming speeds
they do our low altitude training in
tornadoes and um euro fighters and
things and but at one part of it i mean
so they come on through and they um
actually a lot of them your guys were
over um doing it practicing it in um uh
tomcats a few years ago okay um but um
one part of it though there's a there's
a road that goes up over this and it
goes into a lot of holiday makers right
it's steep as hell you know it's like
there's loads of signs when you come up
to it going you know low gear and people
get stuck on it all the time but just as
you come over the brow
is where the fighters come over and they
come over within
maybe 20 meters it's enough that you can
see the pilot and when they come over
you feel the engine you feel the bang as
it comes over and there again there are
signs warning you but when some once
when i was a kid just as we came up to
the thing the tornado went
over
right at the very end of this like
canyon when it's amazing
um it's a terrifying hill though i i've
actually seriously had nightmares about
it it's like oh book as i've got a older
sort of thing i remember had jen
i kept having nightmares that the car
was going to break down as a jet came
over or not nightmares but no dreams i'm
sorry but they're art amazing
it's incredible
um
i actually think star wars though even
though it's not um
it's not my favorite genre i have to
admit i'm a trekkie um but
you know it's just like
that you can't argue with the space
battles even in the most recent
um
most recent uh um uh star wars movie
again i love it when all the you know
the rebels turn up at the end and
there's like it is actually quite a you
know i'm getting hyped up watching
you know it's really cool man
yeah harris you gotta go do it go do it
harris yeah
tell me all right yeah i gotta do it
because you know
virus mine in my little
will be joining us next week for a live
chat he's got his own little youtube
channel and he would he he would love to
come and have a chat with us and he's
gonna next week welcome to the asylum
we're just gonna oh yes exactly we'll
just have an open chat talk about
whatever the hell you like um
our system lord has told us hit that
like button please do also you can
consider joining the channel if you want
to if you are feeling um generous if you
want to support the content
um you know so my wife lets us keep
doing it and uh you know that's the
that's the important thing money money
money money money
it's not why we do it
don't make enough money too that's why
we do
i made 15 this month off my channel
fifteen dollars you lucky in dollars
though like american dollars okay and
yeah us dollars
euros or whatever you guys are using
these days shekels what are you guys
using
we've gone back to the barter system
it's a pain in the ass because every
time i have to go shopping i have to
like take three lambs with me and stuff
like this
i'm just here for some cashews
yeah
um
i'm allergic to cashews that's the one
thing i'm allergic to well they give me
a bag to me but anyway um you're
learning more about me than you need to
if i to cashew
we should do that on stream one day
just eat me cashews and just wait for
the yeah and then they just have
yourself with the epipen right
now it's not that bad i just get a
really bad tummy and and then it's
it's it's my bottom becomes vocal and
smelly at the same time we've got to
bring that oh my god yeah um it's live
streaming farts
yeah they're dramatic that's
well i have a team analogy i'm not
telling you to eat something live on
stream
yeah
then you'll be up to 15 dollars dinky
stinky poop
right anyway let's go back to space
battles sure fine whatever
um
stargate my favorite show look we want
stargate hashtag we want stargate
t-shirts available at sidedashtrek.com i
don't make any money of those
which is brilliant i really should have
probably put a little bit of money on
them i've been a bit of a fool on that
one but anyway um support that we want
stargate to come back
um
they've had some great space battles and
the one thing i like about stargate when
they have a really decent space battle
is a kind of realistic i like the um
f302s how they still use missiles and
things so it still feels you know like i
think the battle over antarctica was a
brilliant space a bit
lower you know obviously we're talking a
little less money than um than stargate
and obviously it's been 20 years since
these shows were made yeah
but also i mean stargate atlantis um i
remember the the the first time when the
wraith attacked the atlantis and where
they all had these rail guns on the
ship really freaking good episode
properly you know tension and the the
added bit where the wraith were coming
in with the um beams beam technology and
actually like scooping people up and
stuff was just like
really good but really exciting and
that's what made a good um space battle
for me is it is the tension that was
built up throughout you know right but
they genuinely they they built it up and
you know you don't know where it's gonna
end and then something happens and the
battle changes and you know it's just
like
some really really good battles
especially in wormhole extreme right
that episode that one not really good
i do love that episode i love it when
stargate was master at turn and things
like that um on its head you know it's
like and they did a few like conspiracy
episodes and things as well this is like
another the my favorite one was the um
because you just mentioned wormhole
extreme but was that you know the guy
who's got the stone oh i can't remember
his name he's got the stone so he's
dreaming about um jack o'neill and
but jack's been dreaming about him as
well she says because
sam's just like sir that you you know
you've been dreaming about a hairdresser
in kentucky for three years and you
never mentioned it
no
never thought to it's like i find it
quite relaxing so
i just i always love that
um
but yeah stargate was always good on
that but i'm gonna throw again a little
bit of a curveball at you
some of the greatest space battles
babylon 5
yes
yes
again we're talking about sort of
realism the whole shadow war thing i
mean it was one thing the shadows were
kind of creepy you know i mean the ships
were creepy
the shadows themselves were creepy
you know always hanging out londo behind
londo's throne when he had that thing
attack i mean the whole the shadows were
just creepy the shadow war yeah creepy
i love the way that series ended the
thing is that that series just had
i liked that it felt realistic right
yeah that you know like howard ships our
out the human um
earth alliance had the big rotating
sections to generate gravity they still
fired what looked like missiles you know
they had laser technology but they
looked like something you'd you'd
actually have in you know that that
would be possible sort of thing
um so i loved all that i loved how the
mambari were more advanced than us but
we could still
you know we still thought
um but they had obviously they had the
shadow wars
then they had the i know before the
shadow was complete they had the
going back to earth because the
president of earth so so um sheridan and
the and the the mimbari force had to go
back to earth and they were i remember
they had this satellite the earth
defense system but they turned it on the
on on earth and so i think so they're
they're rushing and trying to like save
as many lives as they can but you know
going against earth's own defenses so
that i look like the political and the
espionage side of it
and then towards the end
man that was insane yeah
and and then they had the whole thing at
the end with the the vaulons fallons
right
we thought they were the good guys and
then they sort of went you know what the
easiest way to sort this out was just to
wipe
these ways to defeat the shadows is just
to wipe everybody out and start again
and so all of a sudden the vaulons are
the bad guys and we're having to like oh
jesus we have to and then i love that
whole thing we shared in the end just
like knocking the kids heads together
and just just get out of here both of
you we've had enough get the hell out of
our galaxy we're not the children
anymore get out something i'm just like
i felt just like you know just like me
telling the kids off
and i just love that the whole thing
about my life
there's a big problem in terms of
reality
there was a big problem with uh
with babylon 5.
kind of humorous
of course this is the early days of the
internet you know back in the 90s
and
there was some guy
that
calculated uh how much
uh damage to the environmental systems
all of those damn candles were
so he calculated how much paraffin per
day was used you know he you know he he
watched the whole series found out who
had who had candles who was using
candles
you know i think jakar was the biggest
offender full of family he said there's
no way in the world
the atmosphere processors can handle
that much atomized paraffin and he had
this whole calculation for it and it was
i don't know it was the hot meat of the
day back 30 years ago but it was just so
funny that somebody said that's too much
[ __ ] candles for the station
there are beautiful geeks in the world
around there with too much time in their
hands that they
passed right
somebody will come along how much how
much would it cost to build the
enterprise and then
come up with a figure just like based on
how much metal would be required or how
much you know a star destroyer how much
would that cost and then like something
comes up with an answer i'm just like
fair fair play man i do not have the
time the inclination or or the math
ability to do that and obviously there's
no way to check
either as i say
yeah um
how about we're sort of can you think of
any times when like space battles have
then gone or or there's been battles in
movies and you just like go oh christ
they're just that you know that they go
wrong because you know i can't think of
any
i always look at this
or the the the guy
they're just
boring or silly or
or not necessary for the plot or because
they're always
awesome the only thing that really comes
to mind is just it's just a lack of a
special effects budget or they're so
back far back in time like the
50s or 60s you know and there's just not
enough cgi was crap that's the only
thing i can yeah yeah i suppose so i
suppose i mean like i i i did a video
last week they're hopefully going to
it looks like it's about to be greenlit
a remake or a sequel to the last
starfighter um and i love the last
starfighter because it was one of the
very early
cgi um using cgi in sort of like a real
life thing oh yeah and every kid was in
at the arcade on weekends
oh yeah
you've got that you've got tron and
these are the early films and i watched
that now and it just you know whole
death blossom scene does look is a bit
crap
um
but the film's 30 years old
um god no is it nearly 40 years old
it's a late 80s
um but you know
i want to see that
i want to see the death blossom with
seed with decent cgi that'd be cool i
want to see that
um
but um so that that was i did watch that
recently just because researching that
video i love i love having this channel
and this gives me an excuse like oh
they're gonna do uh remake glass style
fighter
1984
what's when that
came out which was the year i graduated
from college
you know how cool would that be if they
green like that soon and get it released
for 2024 on like around the 40th
anniversary yeah how old will that make
most of us 21.
okay i'm not that i was like i was six
i feel a bit old a little bit younger
now
but i wasn't old enough to drink
um
but yeah cgi was pretty bad back then i
mean the ships and things were pretty
good but if you remember like uh the
second star wars when the you know get
the snow scooters they they actually
attack the attacks that cgi was pretty
crap
um i know george lucas when he did again
digitize it he cleaned up a lot but
um
but still you know in 1976 you know
we're looking at this through the eyes
of you know 30 40 years of special
effects
1976 when uh star wars came out 77.
whenever when it came out it was like
no one had ever seen anything like it it
was
amazing you know
i mean people queued around the block
and watched it four five six times
there was one theater in little town i
lived in at the time
it showed it for i mean there was it had
like five viewing five six shows a day
that's all showed for like a year and a
half until the sequel came out until
episode five and we'd go hey you know
and it's not is like 50 cents to go see
it you know get a bucket of popcorn
go watch hey let's go watch star wars
again man it's only 50 cents and we can
get some popcorn and a big soda and just
and then of course we just sit in the
theater all day you know the other
people will come in and go out we just
sit in the back row and just
four episodes of the day
you know
we go in in the morning come out at
night and say well our shift's over
it was very but you know but now looking
back
we did a video to talk to we talked
about this a few months ago didn't we
about how was uh cgi ruined a lot you
know where films better before cgi took
over and i do think there's an element
of i i think the thing we're talking
about with space battles
i think cgi has been massively um
successful because they can scan models
they don't have to actually build them
anymore and this is one of the things
with the star trek um
why you see so many excelsior class
ships get destroyed because they did it
once and they sort of
destroyed the model sort of thing
with little mini explosives and stuff
like this
um and then that's why
they had that
in the in in the bag sort of thing so
that's why you see a lot of excelsiors
get blown up because the models are
incredibly expensive to build
tens of thousands of dollars
um and
you can't blow them up very often
it's just too expensive so you know you
see we think um and then that's why as
well you saw a lot of ships early even
space nine where you're like that ship
looks very familiar if they just took
the warp engines off in excelsior and
sort of flung them underneath and maybe
move their neck a bit back that's that
ship and it's just like yes because
that's that's literally what they would
do they literally would take the model
apart and put it back together a
slightly different way go look there's a
new ship plug
uh you know
they did it but with cgi now
you know we can get
lots of different sorts of ships we can
get lots of different in we get lots of
them you know
cool um you know really cool battles and
they can afford to do it because cgi is
so much cheaper you know and so much
quicker to generate except when you do
picard and you do at the end of the
episode and you forget to add things
like impulse engines to the ship and you
don't bother making more than one ship
you just cut and paste hundreds of
exactly the same ship god i hate that
episode i hate that so much
anyway take a minute
and then they don't shoot they don't
[ __ ] shoot each other there wasn't
even a battle
they built that up so much for there to
be a battle between the the hardest ship
the federation have ever built
apparently and the romulans and then
they didn't even bother
they just they just sort of went ah now
we okay we surrender
chase him and shoot at him the love of
god
sorry okay i'm okay now
um
but yeah so cg i think in that respect
oh i'll tell you a story about cgi
actually which which made me really
interesting it's i find it interesting i
don't care if you do or not
right you know the the they've seen that
serious preacher
yes um
do you remember the opening sequence of
preacher there's look like an old 1950s
rocket and it's flying through space
yeah yeah yeah right sorry to meet you i
just flying through space and it was
supposed to look like those old old tv
shows you know hanging off a wire you
can actually see the the wire and stuff
then in fact
seth rogen was saying they wanted to
actually do that using miniatures
um but it was so expensive and would
take so long it was easier and quicker
to do with cj
and i just think that's
that's just that's that's the world we
live in there
you know
everything's easy to generate on a
computer which is just mad but i think
we've lost something i do think we've
lost something with those i think um
some special effects are better like
hard
special effects right
i might have just incredibly invented a
term there but you know that some
sometimes it's better not to be cgi
you know if an actor can't physically
kick somebody in the head they shouldn't
cgi it you know
it's like
it just looks crap
um
the ancient warship from atlantis yes it
was very cool ah andromeda that was
another one that had really good battles
see there's all these old tv shows that
i really did have good battles yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly it's um
yeah andromeda was on about the same
time that uh babylon five i think was uh
on back in
what one of the uh in terms of like
badass our galactica
the um
the ronald moore version
was season one episode 10 it was the
hand of god you know the the the uh
episode one of that season
it was the 30th it was the they had it
was the countdown you know they were
running from the cylons and they had
this 33 minute countdown that they would
have to jump you know and things were
starting to break
ships were being lost you know and it
was really that's
i mean it was just really emotional like
okay everything's got we got to get out
of here in 33 minutes because somehow
they figure out where we're at
so for the first uh nine episodes
they're being chased chase chase chase
chase and then episode 10 adama just
gets
just screw it we're gonna fight back
and that was probably the first really
big cylon versus the colonial forces
battles that we see and it was awesome
yeah
series excuse me season one that see uh
episode 10.
hand of god hand of god was the name of
the episode
the mini series for me was the same the
second in the second part of the mini
series uh it's the two parts of three
parts
anyway when they have the battle you
know they're in the they go to the
spaceport in that nebula thing and
there's the exit and they're trapped
so um i just i love the way the battle
star it's almost like creating that like
hard shield with the
like the railguns just like putting just
loads of material up but i just love
that the shots and that was the thing
where battlestar galactica wasn't it
they really knew how to build tension
with the battle scenes and they and they
they it built steadily sort of thing to
a crescent it sounds like um a good
piece of music isn't it you know how it
builds to a crescendo sort of thing
um
and
then you know the use of sound and the
use of well and i think that the thing
about battlestar is is it it was the use
of silence as much as the use of the of
sound it really was that was so clever
um
but then you know that that the special
the
the thing is that the battle starts
firing and throwing all that stuff up
and then it sort of like had the shot
where it sort of zoomed out and you
could see like the
spread out it was just so good but it
was it was beautiful as well as sort of
slightly intimidating and a little scary
almost but um that that was capable but
then like say yeah that's saying that
you're about with that fight um i don't
remember any great battle scenes as it
went on
but i actually got a little bit bored of
bubble on fire at a battle star first
time around about about halfway through
the second season i thought i'm bored of
this
um but i went back to it a bit older and
i think i appreciated it more
well i mean it was definitely a more of
a adult level than the first
series you know ronald moore
you know he
you know of course he was the mastermind
behind dxd deep space nine
and uh got a new show on oh he's got not
a new show on apple plus
you know for all mankind and it's just
they're really awesome also he did
outlander a little scottish
love story lost time
he's just a really good filmmaker and
one thing you're talking about sound i
remember
um i'm not sure what battle this was
but uh starbuck the battle's over
starbuck is just in her ship and she can
hear the space debris clinking off of
her canopy
you know and adama says starbuck what do
you hear and she says nothing but the
rain but it was just because it's silent
all the way through you just hear the
radio chatter you know you know you may
hear uh engine
when someone's on speaker you may hear
the thrusters or if you're the the
cameras in the cockpit you hear the
sounds of the cockpit only
but that was when she's just sitting
there and you see all the space debris
clinking on the ship
and that was like god that was just for
me i remembered from all this time it's
just that was really impactful
and yes baltar
no more mr nice guys best line ever
we that we've talked a lot about shows
here from for me was like the golden age
of sci-fi right
late 90s early 90s
we're gonna have to and that we went
into a bit of a no-man's land and now
we're in a second golden age of sci-fi i
think there's loads of really good
sci-fi out there paramount plus is
finally um in the uk so i've actually
started to watch these things i could
get a vpn and watch these things in
america i know but i don't like cheating
it feels like cheating
um but we'll talk about that in a bit
because i've been talking i've been
watching strange new worlds and i've got
an opinion on it so um well do you have
an opinion on it i am i'm regardless of
what some people that leave comments on
my channel seem to believe i'm allowed
an opinion
and if i express my opinion it doesn't
necessarily mean i'm telling you that
you should think the same thing
but you know like that's not some people
seem to believe um
so um i'm just trying to keep up with
the comments that's so good so um
the last couple of years though so if
you think about
i'll tell you what star trek discovery
first series they had some big battles
particularly first couple of episodes
between starfleet and the klingons
is though it was that an example of more
is not always better
because that was a lot of ships
um lots of very pretty
um but i would say um
not particularly good
uh not very entertaining
too slow at times and a bit boring and
things like the klingon the cloaked
klingon vessel
going into the um it was the flagship
wasn't it and destroyed it again looked
great but
i think i agree with you because i mean
i kind of like discovery for series the
first season
and i can't remember one battle
that's because
the clever things about the went on was
uh in that first season was i remember
them putting the bomb on the body
uh the dead klingon they beamed it up
and they blew up the ship that was kind
of clever
you know but the the details of the
battles
they had during season one i just
i know they happened but they really
weren't impactful
yeah i think that was the problem they
didn't really add much to the story but
i do you know it's more is not always
better i always think
um subtlety
and like say it's that thing about
building through a crescendo that was
right that was just
everything out on screen they just
dumped everything on the screen straight
away you know so straight to the money
shop sort of thing um and
they they forgot about the building the
tension they forgot about the
the the the you know the build up the
the cat and mouse thing that was just
ships ships
and and it you know i think it lost a
lot for that and i i really don't think
there's been
i'm not sure discover we've had any
really exciting battle scenes that i
think stuck in your memory even at the
end of series three which would you know
is there there was a huge battle going
on there um
i can't even tell you who they were
fighting
it was the drones or something wasn't
when they [ __ ] drones and i mean you
know i can't i'm not even sure i know
something to do with that species that
we think with the borg but we're not
really sure
um
well let me pick up something you
mentioned the crescendo
crescendo
uh one of my picks for best space
battles is uh
the battle of area 51 in independence
day which everybody and his brother is
watching this weekend here in america
but it was at the very i saw it in the
theater opening day
and this is something i will remember
until the day i die
during the first when when the uh aliens
first attacked they blow up the white
house
or
l.a
and uh i can't remember the character's
name the girlfriend
she has the dog right she's trying to
get out of that
you know she's in a tunnel and all this
is going on and it's building up it's
building up it's building up you know
when she gets out of the car you know
she sees the fireball coming behind her
in the tunnel she gets out of the car
gets into an access tunnel she's
screaming for the
and the dog leaps into her arms she gets
the dog the light bulb goes out
yeah and when i was in the audience
everybody let out a breath of air like
at the same time that was such a good
piece of filmmaking that not just one
person let out a sigh a gasp
of tension
the whole audience did
and that to me was just really power it
was a sign of really good building
building building and i think for me
that was the best example of building
tension and then releasing it
because the light bulb went out and then
it said and then i think there's a title
that said it was a july 3rd or when into
the next day and everybody let out this
big
yeah
and that was it was yeah it was such a
beautiful special effect it was it was a
special effect we haven't quite seen
before right
i do love it when the sci-fi fight i do
love it by the way that you americans
have have created a holiday for around a
movie i mean i think all movies should
have their own holiday i think so um you
know like really good there should be a
star i think probably is a star trek day
um
star wars has got its own day you guys
are really good at that making holidays
for me yeah i mean you know
may the fourth at the star wars day
exactly i'm sorry yeah um it's brilliant
um
but yeah i think that that was one of
those
why that movie is so great because it
did it did flip your you know what you
expected a few times right but it did
have that slow build up and that slogan
you know the whole thing with the
countdown and then but then that special
effect
the color they chose to use for the
weapon for one it was not you know you
you know you wouldn't really think of um
but it was just so big and even then
like when the well you know in the shock
wave or the blast
you know
right you zoom out and you see it's
slowly gone
but even then when you've got the the
final battle sequence and i know some
people take the mickey out of um back
and you know he flies into the weapon
i don't think even that was beautiful
again that they built up it was just
like that it built up to a frantic
tension
and then it's that scene that slows it
all right down and then you've got the
black you know it's just
that is a really good example of space
battles and fighting and it's not fought
in space but these aliens still do um
just the yeah the
the the the rhythm to it is right and
that's right yeah yeah and thank god dr
singh survived that attack
exactly
um i think i i think a lot about like um
old war movies you know it's like when
you've got the um you know the
battleships and then they're playing cat
and mouth and things
and and then again they build up to the
that's that's why that that's when a
really good space battle is good and i
don't think we see that enough in sci-fi
i particularly now it seems to be
everything's going to be on the screen
it's got to be frantic
um
you know i i love firefly i absolutely i
adore firefly but then the
s the attack in the end of the movie
serenity
when they have the um the the reefers
reapers come in at the end and they have
that battle
that was frantic and everything's on
screen
but it's supposed to be
and that that's that's why i love that i
need that so they keep shooting back to
um
i'm a leaf on the wind i'm a leaf on the
wind so i think um
[Music]
that was the
if you want to reboot that was the the
one second that anybody that reboots
firefly is going to regret
oh we've just slaughtered the everyone's
favorite character
oops
oh poor shepherd book did he have to die
damn it
unfortunately that the actor lost his
life so i mean uh
well he got written out ahead of time
oh yeah um but you know that whole
sequence was frantic and
sudden but it was supposed to be and
that's again not why that's such a great
battle scene and again using weapons
that you don't
expect you know because the
the um they're using like you know
harpoons and
just fantastic and that again built the
tension so beautifully towards that
moment
um
trying to think of any others that's
just so
but i just i just i just feel like the
modern star trek
don't do it right even strange new
worlds in the i've only seen the first
three episodes first four episodes
so i've seen the battle with the gone go
on
live trying to remember information
really quickly off the top of my head
it's gone isn't it um they have that
battle sequence and they i felt they
were trying to emulate
um khan a little bit you know they were
fighting in the nebula
um
right right right right each other so
they were sort of like and they used the
navigation system sort of as sensors and
you know that that cat and mouse element
for me though it was let down by the
gorn ships they were really badly
designed
they i just didn't like them at all and
i think if you'd had to make a slightly
scarier looking ship
that sequence that whole sequence would
have worked a lot better
um but again it's beautifully made
and i love to drop in the torpedo
i love
but not forgotten
george flaxman quote of the day
very good yeah you take the mick at me
earlier jamie's got an opinion yeah i do
shocker jamie's got an opinion
that's exactly what my family would say
actually
um
but yeah um i i've actually mentioned um
voyager there voyager had some great
space battles as well yes yes
the voyager has the best finale
episodes i think to any star trek series
but it's the last two episodes of that
are genuinely brilliant
um and uh
and i will argue with anybody that says
otherwise
yeah especially when they're just when
they're back in the solar system and you
know you see this portal open and they
shoot out along with all this junk falls
out you know a blown-up cube
shoots out first and they kind of come
out with the space debris god that was
golden well they were inside the sphere
so it's a sphere that appears isn't it
and then the sphere explodes and the
voyage is inside it so i didn't quite
work out how that works but i like how
they tried because we all knew it was
gonna they were gonna get home but
actually or did we because we you know
maybe they get a movie maybe they get
something else but um
deep space nine
ended they had two episodes too many
and they had a brilliant end and then
they had two more episodes when they
sorted out the whole
he's a god thing
and right like
the real the really good episodes were
two little golden cards i blame that on
you
yeah
tngs was okay
but i mean it's good episodes i watch it
occasionally but
now voyages was the best enterprise
enterprise you can argue about that one
but you loved you some enterprise and
you know it uh honestly some of the best
star trek episodes are enterprise but as
a series it let me down because it
wasn't what it should have been
for me
again i've done a video on this go back
and have a look at that
i've done a video where i just moaned
about enterprise for like 35 minutes
um
for one thing
my biggest in terms of like one single
episode it was uh during the um
where the mirror uni the mirror universe
episode where archer archer's the creepy
mirror
that's just so overacted
i thought right
you know just he's always angry and he's
always he's just he's just
yeah i always think the mirror universe
episodes they were supposed to be over
acted only
and um and that was that was i was i was
really like that they were so overacted
and it was just it was just like go out
there and just alan rickman this to
death you know just go for it you know
just like and they did you know
um
and and i i love that and canceled
christmas um
[Laughter]
and and they all went crazy on it and uh
and i always loved that but okay so on
the space bars before we just sort of
chat nonsense for 10 minutes um as we do
um
one what makes a great space battle and
two what is your favorite thing because
i'm going to rather khan rather khan is
my favorite space battle and i really
hope the next star trek movie basically
remakes of khan properly and has a
really cool space battle in it because
the space battle in the rathacon remake
they've already done was crap
but but what what makes a really great
battle for you what's important [ __ ]
for for me
and and if you
if you look at the list i've been
describing
in in this uh live stream it's
the good guys have a significant chance
to lose which builds tension in the
scene you know i think if the good guys
have a significant chance to lose you
like
stargate season or battlestar galactica
season 1 episode 10 hand of god it was
like
dude they were already losing humans had
already lost now they're just trying to
you know
the the uh the cylons are in a mop up
operation and they have a significant
chance to lose wolf 359 good guys lost
all over the place you know in several
in the video games in the in several
episodes hell q even got had some
commentary about that
babylon funny for call to arms the movie
yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly god that
was i mean you know the battle of the
line
yeah it was just
you know the last call for
you know we know we've asked a lot of
you we're just trying to get as many
ships off the planet we can't ask you to
do and they and these guys these
volunteers get up and they go
you know it's your last mission
honestly for me that's the best babylon
five that's just the risk of losing and
what the hell he encourages tv movie i
you know the stargate did a couple of tv
movies they were they were they were
pretty good the the the person was great
but
babylon five smashed that out of the
park of course yeah they did you know
really really i'd like to see i'd like
to see um
really like to see more of that
maybe not a remake but something of
course after the shadows and the
warlords leave or what else is there
left to tell but i'd like to maybe see a
remake or something about i don't know
well next year it's supposed to be
coming
yeah i really see that
yeah i think it's good ah that is a good
point we we forgot about the expanse
i mean we there's just probably about
30 or 40 more franchises that we've
forgotten about oh yeah
how about you know uh thanos against the
the asgard the last ass guardianship
yeah
that was a short battle
i love the expanse particularly in the
first series though because it was so
again you're talking about building up
tension and the first series when that
ship they don't know and they don't know
what it is he's coming towards him and
they're the martians they think they've
got the biggest baddest ship on the on
the block and it just spanks some sort
of thing but i love the bit where
there's um
around from one of the rail guns goes
through the ship and she's going
and then they sort of turn around and
somebody's the one guys lost his head
yeah
i love that song that's cool um
but but yeah for me it's it is about
um like you said that
there's got to be a chance of losing i
do quite like the loads and loads of
ships and everything's going crazy but
i'd rather it be a little simpler
and um it's like you said like the star
wars example when the battle's going on
in the background
and they keep flipping in and out of it
and it's just and that's all crazy loads
going on in the background i quite like
that but um when it's
when it's um
i think the best space battles are when
it's a lot simpler and i've remembered a
movie um a naval movie um mastering
commander with russell crowe yes paul
benny was in it and a couple of others
and there's a lot in there
yeah yeah oh yeah the whole movie is
this um you know the ship that's
outgunned by this french frigate just
chasing them down and again it's a cat
and mouse thing and the whole the whole
movie's building towards that
you know i i really want to see and i
and i honestly i can't name any other
maybe rather khan one or two others
that have that sort of
you know that tension that build up that
the whole movie is about the the the the
different aspects of the battle sort of
thing and i want to see more of that
because i think it really works and in
sci-fi
really works
but with cgi
and things it's almost like movie makers
every single time they have something
they have to do better they have to do
more they have to do bigger they have to
do you know yeah you know what simplify
it works a lot better there's some of
the best cgi now today if you if you
watch the original predator movie
simple
simple special effects
and and subtle
building up towards the you know the
final thing at the end
i want to see movie makers do that more
because they do far too much of
let's just make sure that we can throw
as much on the screen as we possibly can
and do
we had more ships than the last movie
did you
well done
and i'll tell you one really bad example
of that is the last star trek movie
beyond
um when they have those drones things
that have make no physical sense and
obviously
yeah the little buzzy
thingies
things and that the one scene is very
cool when they you know do the beastie
boys song
and they do the sweeping thing and
they'll start blowing up very visually
cool um but from a battle point of view
bloody awful
um it's you know it's it's not good
it's not a good space battle it's not
good star trek
looked great but you know
it's not the same
so anyway that's one of the
in terms of just on-screen battles
that's really sci-fi one with lots of
cgi
the the one i really liked the most was
uh
um sauron versus the ants in the two
towers
near the ends of just
absolutely fed up
some of these trees were my friends
and they just go and [ __ ] a wizard up
release the river
the river comes crashing down the
goblins go flying and drowning and [ __ ]
one of those troops is my cousin
you know and i love that scene i really
wish
that they had put out little like you
know you see these little green army men
toys
they should have had those for ants i
would have bought you know
bunches of them just so i could play you
know
true
well i think we've got that covered i
think we've done well lesser and uh
55 minutes well this you've got four
minutes and 50 seconds to tell me what
you've been watching this week because
we're not going over we connect we can
actually go over an hour tonight because
i was running late so i don't mind
you can you talk rubbish
oh have you frozen
stormy's frozen
i'm on my own
we'll wait for him to come back i'll
tell you what i've been watching this
week so i've started to watch stargate
uh now i've started to watch um star
trek strange new worlds
and i'm going to tell you
i've i've got mixed feelings about it
um
i love the characters i love the captain
obviously i love um
uhura and i love the uh the pilot woman
with the cool hair i really like her
hair
and
storming has left the building
um so
the characters are great and it's really
character-driven
i
don't like how people looks personally
now it's okay
um i do think that the story
the stories they're having i like the
episodic nature of them but i can't see
where it's going
and the thing that i think it's a really
interesting and really good show at the
moment but it's not going to be a great
show
unless they have
a really good bad guy
and at the moment i can't see where
that's going to come from
got no idea it just went blue
i'm just gonna tell you about my
concerns about strange new worlds so i
really like the character
the pilot i love i love her i think
she's such a good character i can't
remember her name but um i love her hair
as well
um and i love the episodic nature of it
i love how it's getting back to star
trek to its roots sort of thing but for
a tv show to go from good to great you
need a really good bad guy
and i can't see and without really screw
in with cannon i can't see how strange
new worlds can do it i can't see how
they can they can bring in a bad guy
that that's going to be enough of a
threat
that's not gonna like i said
peel over cannon
um and i'm really worried that they're
basically just going to start remaking
the original series episodes
you know kirk being in it next year is a
massive concern but i love the
characters
in a way i hope they don't try
to to
to maybe bring in a big existential
threat and they just keep it the
episodic nature of it maybe
but then we are only going to get the
gone
that's going to be about it
the
it is predator
meets aliens meets
yeah star trek i mean dude
yeah so we'll get to that we'll get to
that but i do have concerns about it
becoming going i think it'll be a good
show
and if they
honestly if they bring in kirk next year
i don't see how that's going to work
unless he is only in for a few episodes
but he's quite a
quite a big actor just to bring back for
a few episodes
he could just come in there's nothing in
canon to say that kirk wasn't aboard the
enterprise for a bit
um
the
way he should be is is aboard the uh
there's the incident um if we're gonna
go with time uh
the farragut it should be aboard the
farragut well that incident should have
just happened so they could write that
into something but i'm just worried
they're gonna start they're just gonna
reboot and remake
the original series
and that'll be crap
i won't i won't be impressed and i want
to see pike anyway i like the i like um
i think the mount is a great actor i
really do like him in that part yeah i
think they should just stick with that
they've got a good few years and they've
already told us actually that the
incident where he gets disfigured is 10
years off i actually think they've got
the math wrong on that a little bit
it should be five years off but i i will
need to go double check that i'm pretty
sure five years but he says it's 10
years off so in that the next space we
should have 10 years of pike as captain
but you know him and number one had a
conversation about that what if it's
something that he puts off something
that he does
you know does it even you know in his
timeline does that even happen did he
see it you know when we were watching uh
uh original series
did he go through those events to see
his death
he seemed to have because in the
original series you know um
it seemed that they there was a lot of
questions he had about where he was at
that should have been answered
ten years prior but wasn't so i'm kind
of curious of
are we in another timeline
if they do that again
i might have to find
uh
the creators and have words i if we're
in
i don't i don't want to make physical
threats on on youtube because you know
there's the evidence against me um you
know i might have to have a stern
conversation with them
strong awarded email yes strongly email
um
but but yeah i'm hoping they don't do
that because i'm sick of them doing that
um and i really like canon but anyway
strange new worlds i'm enjoying it a lot
and i've started to watch prodigy as
well and i'm really enjoying that don't
normally go for a cartoon but like
actually no that's a complete lie i love
cartoons so um yeah
i know i i like uh trainer janeway
yeah i love that i thought it's just
clever um i don't like the ship designs
which is a bit annoying because they
could design the ships any way they
wanted but it's a bit like lower decks i
hate i don't like the ship designs
but um i know i don't like the um the
sweetest but um
actually the titan and stuff's cool but
uh
you know i i don't i don't like the
prodigy designs but yeah what are you
gonna do uh kind of everything
but whatever the other thing i did watch
this week and i was genuinely blown away
by
was the boys
again dear god yes
now are you is the uk in the united
states synced yeah yeah so we just had
episode five
i want to say five but anyway it's where
it's the episode so
um homelander got his butt kicked
and um then the soldier boys just phoned
him so that like this one was the with
the guy with the mind control thingy
that was the last episode wasn't it and
um
oh spoilers spoilers if you haven't seen
it
um uh so
seven we're talking about soldier boy is
episode seven so soldier boys told him
that i'm your dad we had that star wars
moment yes yes uh which
who's your daddy uh it's me hello uh so
yeah i mean it's so that was that was
really really good um i i actually think
the boys and this is might be going to
be
um you know confrontational order it
might be my favorite tv show on the tv
at the moment
like actually new week in week out
that's the show i look forward to coming
out i'm just like he
what they're going to do this week
it's like it like it tickles my naughty
not my naughty boy inside me
yeah it was um
this week
i think me and my girlfriend both said
like what the [ __ ] at the very end when
soldier boy you know makes the
revelation he
he donated some
human cells
into a cup
and gave it to him
and they did they did that whole scene
and only though only the way the boys
can and like if you're easily offended
for the love of god don't watch the boys
do you guys get the warnings that we get
like out here it's it's uh like 18 plus
and there's like this big like this is
terrible no we really didn't [ __ ] the
octopus no our animals were harmed in it
i mean they go on in great detail
we don't have that so much but it does
there is a warning at the start going
you know don't don't just don't watch it
did they talk about the animal abuse
no i don't think so
who could possibly think that there was
actually using
that the guy was
masturbating with an octopus
i mean that's i i know there's no
warning about it you're here in the
united states the octopus is not real
calm down
um
but yeah there is there is a warning
about you know this is actually you
shouldn't watch this just don't watch it
i don't want to start out
um it's this is it's it's it's something
like yeah that bad things will happen we
do go over the top you probably
shouldn't watch it
which i love
um
what's this so i've been displaying
strangely well since i played this
strange new world's release date 2000.
okay
um
but uh what else did i watch this week
that i enjoyed oh so i suppose you
should mention the orville
right i'm a little disappointed by the
oval
it's kind of slow isn't it yeah i was
hoping for more you know the the the
advert and the run-up to it new horizons
looked so cool and i mean that's had
some great space battles you know that
yeah yeah yeah i throwing everything on
the screen
um
the last episode i'm not understood it
made sense we did get lots of the creel
and in my head all the time when i
watched the episode going
if you if you if you say like that
they're not scary anymore
and you know it's like oh no the cleaner
going to attack
we're all in danger
um you know but
i thought it was a little not silly but
i know people are jumping all over it's
woke i get lots of comments it is woke
because we did a video or the orville is
not woke
and they've got a lot of comments going
yes it is i'm like it's not it's awake
it talks about serious matters but you
know it doesn't ram it down your throat
and the story is the primary
um driving force behind it you know so
you know i don't care that it's got
layers and there's you know it's trying
to you know if there's a social
commentary if the story is the main yeah
you know isaac's um
suicide yeah exactly people get really
upset about that and you know that was a
uh
you know suicide is a
it's a serious issue here in america
there's like we just don't treat
we don't take mental health seriously
here in america
we try to
but um
it's a big problem i think all over the
world particularly with men
um in males particularly
we commit suicide more than than than
women quite scarily proportionate it's
like it's like five or six times more
than women do in this country
which is um
but um
yeah it's it's a yeah it is a serious
issue and they tackled it but they
tackled it in a way that was relevant to
the story and that's that's the
difference between and i do appreciate i
hate the term woke i hate it
um
but i do i do have to concede that the
you know there's people that get do
angry about this they do have a point
with some some tv shows i don't think
it's as bad as they make out but um but
in some tv shows but the but
the orville is awake it's not woke yeah
i mean and the people that the the the
term woke was manufactured by fox news
here in the united states so i mean you
know consider
or it was twisted into a bad thing by
fox news i mean it was i've been around
a while hasn't it but
um but but yeah i say yeah it deals with
deals with important things but at the
end of the day
it's um but george we bottle our
feelings up yeah we do push them down
into a dark place right in the pit your
stomach went out a whole star trek
episode or c uh t movie
i need my pain
yeah i need my pain man um yeah that's
why
every second
um but yeah man
but
i i just think that's you know you've
got seth macfarlane who's the obviously
the creator he writes almost all the
episodes and he's the drawing force
today it's he uses it as a way to talk
about things he wants to talk about and
that's what's so good sci-fi is supposed
to be it's supposed to be you know it's
it's using
metaphors and imagination to
talk about real things you know and it's
not just about boo boo lasers it's about
you know it's there
there are supposed to be layers to this
damn thing so i like that although
metaphor
about what's going on in the world today
that's all what the original series was
about original star trek series yeah
yeah i mean it was i mean back then it
was the you know the conflict between
united states and the soviet union and
you know the ever impending doom of
total nuclear holocaust i mean that was
the metaphor you know the klingons
versus the federation that was that was
what it was
you know and
you know it tackled
everything and what you know and i think
the people that are are amazed or
well that wasn't that you know that
wasn't
you know when you heard a kiss kirk that
wasn't woke oh yes it was i mean there
were
articles there were people um
writing campaigns to um
to the network about how could you
possibly put this on television
because that's one of the arguments to
say well nowadays they used to do it
subtly but nowadays they just ram it
down your throat there was a character
in star trek that was half black and
half white and he was being persecuted
because the black was on the wrong side
that doesn't get much more not supple
that was racism
you know um
it's welcome to the enterprise [ __ ]
shoot the kill shoot the kill shoot the
kill you know i was just like
ah
is the over what modern expressway i
think the orville is a love letter to
what star trek used to be
myself
yeah
it's you know the type thing but anyway
but yeah so i've i've i'm enjoying
sci-fi i really think we're in a bit of
a golden age so i think i picked a good
time to start a sci-fi youtube channel
you did well
you know since the streaming services
popped up i mean
before the streaming services all we had
to do was the sci-fi channel
s-y-f-y right yeah and you know we did
get some things we got a dune
mini-series out of that that comes to
mind you know we did get battlestar
galactica anyway
dark matter is great dark man oh god
and as soon as it becomes really good
they cancel right so then it was just
like um we're left with wrestling on the
sci-fi channel
uh but now we've got all these streaming
services that's offering top quality
uh
sci-fi
you know we talked a little bit about
apple plus you know for uh there's this
one series all mankind it's also done by
ronald moore from battlestar galactica
and deep space nine and it is excellent
it's about what would happen
is is all about the space race
and um
what would happen what how would america
react and what would the story be if the
russians if the soviets got to the moon
first
and it is gripping
gripping um
storytelling it really is
the sci-fi also had
something that's very i didn't think was
ever going to get made but his
foundation
by isaac
brilliant
that's that's one of those shows
definitely it's a bit like the ring
coming out or ringworld sorry um if that
ever gets greenlit but um
yeah it's one of those tv shows that i
don't think could be made
a few years ago it couldn't it couldn't
it wouldn't succeed on networks but it
can on
stream streaming service a show it's one
of those shows as well that streaming
services don't care as much about
numbers as a network does they don't
care about figures as much because as
well you can watch it whenever you like
so you know some of these shows they are
slow burners the firefly if it was on a
streamer service would never have been
cancelled ever
not the way it was anyway because they'd
have made the whole series they'd have
dumped it on there in one hit
and then they'd have just waited and
people would have had a chance to fall
in love with the series
whereas on the network the viewing
figures weren't great straight away so
they went out we're done with it
yeah sort of thing you know streaming
services however whatever stream systems
are not always a good thing and i do
think they're going to be the death of
cinema that they're killing killers
um but
they're um
you know they are they are bringing
really really good tv series and i think
we'll boil i think we've got too many
streaming services i think they will
boil down to two or three maybe four
big ones the big boys you know i think
netflix is in trouble
um but but disney hbo max
amazon amazon won't go anywhere and
maybe paramount i think paramount's
another one that might be in trouble
long term i don't think it'll survive or
get absorbed into hulu or something
it'll get absorbed into the kind of
already phone i think anyway
yeah
uh one of the things i watched this last
week was uh
it it well it was the latest doctor
strange movie you know multiverse of
madness what did you think because i
didn't like it that much
i i liked it one of the things i liked
was you know they were trying to figure
out well which parallel universe are you
from i'm from 638 which one are you you
know and it was just
okay which ca and any kind of
you're tr kind of figuring out as you go
well who's which one is attack well
which
you know where's all this going you know
and um
one thing my girlfriend and i watch this
and one thing we will say is like when
we were always
we were glued to the screen because if
you look away man you don't know what
yeah
there's so many easter eggs as well
there's so many yeah oh god easter eggs
and another thing this is not really a
sci-fi series maybe kind of
uh it was chris pratt
the terminal list
i haven't seen it yet but yeah it's it's
on amazon isn't it i've not seen it yeah
yeah and so just briefly with hardly any
spoilers it's about this uh seal team
guy
mission goes bad he's trying to get this
uh
this uh terrorist chemist
and then
the when he gets back the story of what
happened is different than what he
remembers so he starts suspecting that
well you know maybe someone's lying
about something or another and some
events come forward and say well no that
wasn't a lie
and um
but then we find out
there he was
uh he he was legitimately uh paranoid
because [ __ ] was happening in the
background
but now then the the the
show is interlaced with um
previous memories
memories that's really not associated
with anything turns out he's got a tumor
in his head and is like watching the
multiverse of madness okay was this
something he imagined or did this happen
in the past or which version of you know
sometimes he's got the gun sometimes he
doesn't have the gun sometimes he's
dressed in
a different way for a different scene
and he's like
this is the multiverse of madness with
chris pratt oh my god
but i loved it and the only reason i
stopped watching episodes last night was
but it got really late and so we had no
internet
one of the reasons why i've got bags
under my eyes is because i was watching
stranger things and i watched the season
finale that was supposed to be the
series finale about halfway through the
series the duffel brothers decided you
know what we need another series
and netflix went okay do that
um so we're going to get a fifth series
and but it was good um parrots and you
stormy next week um should have a good
chat because like say harris he likes he
was actually in
he is in the terminal list and he's in
one of the background actors but he does
a lot of things so you guys are going to
get on like a oh sometimes and he is
um uh other american
so he's you'll never get the title of a
resident american harris but you'll be
the other american too bad for you
harris
63rd
i'm not even going to come by his name
i'm just going to come the other
american throughout the entire stream um
just to amuse myself
um but yeah stranger things i have
thoroughly enjoyed
um it's one of those series that um
a little bit iconic actually it's like
you know it actually affected culture as
a whole and i've really really enjoyed
it um i thought the third series was um
the second series was a bit slow the
third series really picked back up again
but this fourth series has been
brilliant
i really enjoyed it and lots going on
and uh let's look forward to the fifth
season because everything's gone to [ __ ]
at the end of the fourth
so happy happy days
right
happy
happy
i'm looking forward to like season six
of the expanse if it ever comes you know
um the the well i'm being too old
is from uh people i speak to is that
they there won't be a season
uh
six
or not anytime soon but a spin-off
series is possible
so that's possible
um and there's lots of storytellers and
that's actually
the the filmmakers know that's possible
and that's why if you watch the last
season there's lots of little lots of
little story arcs don't really go
anywhere
and you're wondering like oh why haven't
they done that it's because they know
but they said that's what i'm being told
anyway they know there's a pretty good
chance that they can get this sort of a
spin off seriously so it'll be
it'll be it'll still go at the expanse
but it'll be
a much smaller much more focused mini
series
right
and what the one of the main things is
that um
apparently is the point is is that
they're not going to get any more money
to um as the budget the budget will be
the same as what the expanse was which
was already tight yeah but we're making
a more focused less
less sets less things so then that is
that is a more achievable
goal sort of thing for the series and
that is possible but it won't be this
year
so
at the moment amazon uh
um well again the thing i'm being told
is
uh amazon executives are very nervous
that they might have overspent on lord
of the rings
um and that's blasted their budget
well if you're going to uh blow your
budget on something please do it on lord
of the rings yeah everything you'll be
sacrificed throw it away don't look for
lots of people that haven't even seen it
are very angry about it
so um you know the you've said more than
once on this series that if you want to
see a really committed fan base look at
the tolkien fan base you know they're
they're insane
um but you know we'll get you we don't
care
exactly i've never had brown coats you
know
trekkies you know stand to one side
um but but that's one thing but also the
mgm merger has caused them oh and the
slowdown in streaming service
subscriptions have started causing a few
concerns but the big thing is that the
mgm merger has not been as um
simple as they thought
and um and things have gone a bit
sideways with a few projects but
basically they've gone in and reviewed a
lot of what mgm's been doing over the
last 12 months and hated all of it
that's what i mean that was the one
thing i was told was they reviewed some
movie that was about to be greenlit and
they scrapped it immediately and he
didn't he didn't tell me what it did to
me was called but i can't remember
um and apparently one executive went if
that's an example of what they're doing
we're all [ __ ]
um and then
we've waited nine billion dollars
amazon um
did get uh scrounged up a lot of tolkien
scholars legitimate scholars
and a lot of the bigger names in the
fandom like the guy that runs uh
onering.net that's been running it
forever
um
and
and they all came away with really
positive
uh really positive attitudes toward
i think the first three rough cuts that
they saw i think it was uh this is
detailed if you want to um read more
about this it's on the onering.net
buried down a couple months ago
but so you know if tolkien scholars are
good with it and you know some of the
bigger names in the fan base is good
with it i'm kind of
i'm not as panicked as um
i know it's people or about kenobi i
mean because you know there's so many
people on twitter that was just
this is going to ruin it that's going to
ruin it oh my god if this character's in
it's going to ruin it you know and oh
they found whole different ways to ruin
it
i i'm not a fan of that series i don't i
haven't seen the last episode yeah i
haven't had chance with family
commitments
and lots of other stuff i know the last
episode is supposed to be the
the the dream but um up until the first
five episodes
they're not great
they've been quite hard to watch
or to stay awake through
um but but again i'm not a big star wars
fan but ain't like me with this is how i
felt when they announced discovery i was
nervous because i'm i am a trekkie
that's me down to my core i've become
more of a gator in more recent years
because i i don't like some of the new
trek so i'm more but when stargate
finally gets announced i'm going to be
[ __ ] it
i'm not a
big a fan of
i'm not obsessed with tolkien i love the
lord of the rings and i love the books
when i was a kid i'm not as obsessive as
as yourself and others um but i will
watch it with a completely open mind and
i will love it or hate it based on what
i see on the screen i will not hate it
because some thing is wrong you know one
i actually just say that one of the
characters is it one of the elves is a
black guy
and that's a problem and i'm like are
you kidding me
that's what you're angry about
you need to have a look at yourself
yeah like you know calm you really need
to look at yourself and calm down
um and if that's this level of d well
there would know there were no
characters like that in the tonkan book
but maybe you just didn't mention them
calm down
uh you know the
tolkien in some unfinished tale i think
he was talking about um the hard foots
the hobbits it was a kind of a a
i don't want to say subspecies of
hobbits but it's like a family of
hobbits
and some of those tended to be darker
skin and i think it was just an un is
like somewhere an unfinished tale and it
was so obscure that i'm even having a
hard time remembering where it was from
but like tolkien wrote more than one he
wrote [ __ ] tons of stuff i mean he's got
notes and notes and notes and they've
been publi what there's ten volumes of
just notes that you can buy off of
amazon from orderings
yeah exactly so what did he say i just
saw a clip of that i'm coming after him
where's my where's my gollum
i'm sorry but we're not all as excited
about the lord of the rings i will watch
it
i will probably enjoy it greatly but
then i will probably turn it over and
watch the witcher and enjoy even more
so um
the witch is a good show
the truth is a good show
oh my god that damn bard i love he's my
favorite character
somebody didn't have a beard
yeah
let's go let's see these likes why not
hear me listen lord
um
and like i said if you are watching this
video and you have never seen that
contact before where you've been for the
last 10 months yeah
subscribe and blah blah blah
and like i said if you enjoy the content
and you enjoy listening to this crazy
resident american waffle on about lord
of the rings
consider joining the channel it really
helps us out
lord of the rings
it's not even sci-fi you shouldn't even
be talking about it it's fantasy what do
you want about
so um take it all back
rewind
no no
why not why not no precious no
we talk about whatever the hell we want
to talk about on this show whether it's
like they are not it's called freedom
why do you hate freedom so much
[Laughter]
with it being the fourth of july
tomorrow why do you hate democracy
why do you hate tea
that's just you americans
like i i
honestly if t
if there's a tea shortage tomorrow i'd
be dead in three days
it's there's a real problem with it you
americans are so and you hate them you
hated the british so much back then you
sort of went well let's take
let's remove the ampo nectar the the
most amazing drink ever made and let's
have this a bitter tasting crap instead
not because it's better just because you
hate the british and that's all the only
reason you like drink coffee well have
you been to the american south
uh no actually no dude
it's uh tea
is the stand ice tea
is the standard drink
see i mean they don't even ask you
a restaurant sometimes don't even ask if
you want tea they just serve it to you
if you want water you have to ask for
that
you know so they give you these big big
huge glasses right 16 ounces and they'll
fill they'll keep it topped off
throughout the entire meal
you know and so
pretty soon you've already had 64 ounces
of just tea
and then hey do you want that in the go
cup and then when you go out they give
you a big 32 ounce styrofoam
uh cup full of iced tea on your way out
with lemon
and they're very friendly as well yeah
they still like a bit of slavery but
very friendly no i mean
we drink more coffee here than we ever
have done anyway you know with costa
coffee and starbucks and you know
everyone and it's just i just don't like
it it's too bitter for me but i i do try
to drink some because
i do have jealousy for those people that
um drink coffee because i'd love to have
a percolator you know like set in the
morning to go
now before i woke up sort of thing and
because this it smells amazing it smells
so nice
it's just too bitter for me i just can't
drink it
yeah um there is a very distinct
possibility that there will be a i've
just done the video about it go back and
watch the video
just don't ask me here i've done the
video but yes space of one beyond great
space battles i might be getting a
reboot do you know what that this is it
does make me laugh that the space will
beyond might get a reboot simply because
disney plus can't figure out what to do
with firefly
and that's the reason
and they want to do firefly
they've they've written five pilot
scripts and they've all been crap
so they've gone ah
let's just space the bum and beyond it's
like
that's just so lazy that's just like me
when i'm trying to do you know when i'm
trying to fix something and i can't
quite do it oh
i'll go paint the kitchen instead it's
just like you know it's just like which
i actually do is it is it a reboot of
firefly or something after the events of
uh serenity of the events on miranda
what i'm being told is that they've done
five uh four or five pilots
they've tried to do a complete reboot
and so one of them was a just complete
reboot but mostly they're looking at a
sequel
so um so they did a couple of like
sequel things where there would be an
extension of the story they didn't work
so they went how about we just start
again
and then um apparently john favreau was
actually brought isn't a consultant
and he just went this is all crap
um so they've just at the moment
it's it's it's up in the air they don't
know what they're doing with it
um
yeah yeah but apparently favre was a
huge is a huge fan and there were rumors
um
on another youtube channel he was
actually going to come in as a
showrunner um
but that was
that was just because they
he went in as a consultant they put two
and two together and got five sort of
thing
and they need their sauces
some uh some english mustards what they
need but um but yeah um
but that's the things you know john
favre just came in because he loves the
series and he's here he said like they
asked him to come in and have a look
he's gonna figure out what to do with it
and he just went this whole crap this
won't work
so um
so yeah so that's good
i i at least prefer that they've got the
balls to go this is [ __ ]
you know
let's not do it
um you know and it's like so i i
appreciate they've got the balls to do
that because you know there's nothing
worse
than a you know something that you're
that excited about coming back star trek
and it being not very good
you know
this took them until now to make strange
new worlds
um so yeah so yeah i don't know about
that but space above and beyond again
which they own i think would make a
great series and it's the sort of series
again that would never have been
cancelled on a streaming service
that's true sometimes i think you're
right on that
because i loved it i mean i watched
every episode is it is the old
is the is it still streamed someplace
space above and beyond is that i was on
disney plus around christmas time
because i started to watch it
um but now it's gone
i wonder if it's gone in the u.s or if
it was just apparently yeah apparently
it's gone pretty much everywhere
um because i actually said in the video
go and watch it it's on disney plus and
then everybody came in and went it's not
and i'm like it was i 100 started to
watch it at christmas time
um because i've got it on dvd so i
started watching because i watched i've
got dvd player in my room so i started
watching i've watched the rest of the
series and i'm nearly at the end
on the dvd in my room but i started to
watch it downstairs where i've got
disney plus
um but it's gone off but i think that
might be a good sign because i do wonder
whether they put these on sometimes just
to see what the viewing figures are
and but then you're not going to want it
on disney plus if you've then got a new
series coming as well
which will be a complete reboot it will
not be an extension of the original
series it'll be it'll be like it never
existed
so you don't want it on the streaming
service so it might but again maybe i'm
two and two plus five equal there you
know maybe i'm seeing more
i'm ex maybe i'm
thinking that they think about these
things a bit more than they do but
um it would definitely be taken off if a
new series was coming they wouldn't have
the old one as well
right um i'm trying to see if you can't
get it anywhere really um
there's some really extreme umly weird
streaming services you can get it on but
it's like you have to order it sort of
thing you have to like pay for it i
don't know if it's on amazon actually i
haven't looked
um but i've got the dvds from like 20
years ago
um
so i i don't even know if you can buy
the dvds
but it's a serious people love
yeah
i wonder where it is streaming
so answer the question there judge him
that i think i think the problem with
firefly is it's really really loved
space moving on there's been
a long enough has gone um long enough
distance you know it's so long ago it's
like 30 years ago and people have kind
of forgotten about a reboot won't piss
too many people off
firefly is too loved people really love
that series and if they get it wrong
well
a lot of people are just going i'm not
watching it
um i don't want to watch it um or if
joss whedon isn't involved which would
be difficult i don't want to watch it um
you know because of joss whedon his
issues
um and josh sweden would have to be
involved in some way because his
production company own
own the story um even though the
production rights are owned by fox
um but it's it's it's too loved
and it's too it's still reasonably
recent even though it's been 20 years
nearly right um getting firefly right is
complicated space but beyond
you just start again you've got a
storyline you've got a plan for five
series you just do it you just crack on
and make it
firefly is complicated
well i'm seeing some links it says it's
uh space above beyond is on hulu here in
the united states
cool which is uh owned by disney isn't
it
it's owned by
nbc it's owned by some of the broadcast
company which are now owned by disney of
course yeah oh there you go
so yeah batman says that it's uh on
dailymotion which is i think where i
found it
on youtube
or youtube yeah um you can get it
through youtube definitely i watched a
few i watch a few episodes just so you
can watch on youtube it's also on sling
if you're on the sling network but yeah
it's showing
hulu now how some of these sites are not
always
that is pretty much the only series i've
not heard
any rumors about but there's no
intention of remaking fast paper
um
i've got it i know i've got the whole
series on dude i love farscape because
that's the promises i think they
because the sources that i speak to the
people i speak to they they
you know they are quite close to um some
of the studios so it's amazing how many
things they do all our meetings shall we
do this shall we do that and it never
goes anywhere you know
on the shall we and then somebody will
go in no and then there just doesn't go
any further than that
um which is why stargate is so
infuriating because i keep hearing about
meetings such meetings after meetings
after meetings and it's like that's
great and it's exciting because it feels
like they're talking about it
when will any of it go anywhere you know
to say when will it go to the next bit
um but but these you know it's hundred
million dollars they'll spend on let's
see the first series of stargate they're
going to talk about it a lot
um but they talk about everything but
like so you hear rumors about all sorts
and then it's trying to pick and choose
what do you want to do a video about and
what do i or what do i think might go
somewhere or what will never go anywhere
and farscape is one of the one the very
few series i've never heard i even heard
recently there's a tv series called
space precinct and it was made by jerry
anderson
the bbc were thinking about maybe
rebooting that jesus
you're wondering if farscape is a
special case i don't know if is is it
owned by a st i think it's owned by the
jim henson company isn't it
and they're still independent it
wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me now
that i'm pretty sure disney on them
i think disney owned jim henson
um when they because they bought them
because of the muppets
who i wonder if they just bought the
muppets
i'm not sure
hmm they're
handsome
because it's a jim henson production and
has only showed on um
[Music]
it was only on the sci-fi channel
never got picked up by anywhere else i
don't think
they have a merger degree they have a
merger agreement so they merged with
disney in 1989. oh no oh sorry but the
deal fell through
ah
the the company is still owned by the
henson family
so yes they were going to buy them but
that's where i've got that from them but
they didn't happen so
so that's why no one's talking about
fire escape this is not owned by the
lake because nobody owns it
yeah no fraggle rock that's why you want
to come back
so they're not doing anything with their
intellectual properties they own other
than maybe
do they own sesame street
yeah on the muppets so other than sesame
street not really doing anything with
their
their intellectual properties really
so so you ought to do a video why disney
hates farscape that's the title that's
the clickbait right and then we just
[ __ ] about disney not really mentioning
stars
far escape i'm planning a video at the
moment
um why do we have so many freaking
reboots
and it's just i think it might just be
um
we've finally talked about something
that shelley
wants to talk about
congratulations shelly we're thinking
about you
um
bbc should bring back red dwarf but it's
a problem again is that the the it's so
so character driven you'd have to bring
back
you know that those characters are so
loved you know and then i know dave
brought it back which is a channel over
here the term it's on sky sort of thing
and they they brought it back to them
that was only a couple of years ago they
did another dwarf a red dwarf episode
but it's
it's so character driven you have to
wait longer for people to forget about
the original until you can do something
like that well it's like you know um
bbc did the original series uh live
action series uh hitchhiker's guide
yeah which i thought was awesome yeah
you know
done a bit in 70s or early 80s it was
done a bit ago shot on video you know
low scan video but it was awesome
and then they did um a movie
al allen rickman was uh you know marvin
the robot the depressed robot
it was terrible they weren't saying it
was awful i mean
i mean slaughter they should have just
taken slaughty bart forrest out in the
back and just shot him i mean it was
just
i i really you know
and
i don't know it's just
the bbc have a mixed relationship with
sci-fi they the doctor who is successful
so they think they can do sci-fi and
when they do stuff in conjunction with
america
it's normally good but like that space
precinct tv show it wasn't particularly
great
um
it wasn't jim henson it was jerry
anderson oh okay eventually it was jerry
anderson
um but it was like a million pounds an
episode but it was like 30 years ago to
make it was really expensive to make
and it's like the bbc because they just
thought it thunderbirds was popular at
the times they thought it would sell
well in america it just didn't
go um but yeah
they don't have the budget and and when
sort of channel 4 or itv or other like
networks over here try to make sci-fi
it's generally even
and we worse
don't have the budget
they don't have this the the spend even
when they have good ideas and good
stories they tend to be we tend to do
dystopian stuff better
well i'll tell you you know the uh
downton abbey is
awesome right
but
they did want like uh i think hbo is
doing one of the same creative teams
called the gilded age on hbo
and i hate it
same writer same production i hate it
because
you know in downton abbey everybody
everyone's most people most characters
have a nice side
you know
in the gilded age they're all americans
and they're all [ __ ] the guys you're
supposed to be rooting for are [ __ ]
the guys are that are the bad guys
they're still [ __ ]
there's only one character on there that
is halfway decent and the only reason
she's halfway decent is because she
doesn't have any damn money
you know and so it was just like
can't wait
god
this is america i don't want to watch
this [ __ ]
i don't even watch everyone's playing to
each other in the original
it was like airs and graces and all that
[ __ ]
um bring back captain jack for torchwood
why not um
brilliant oh speaking of jack
gentleman jack
also very good
on hbo
watch channel
it's a true story about the
and
and something entirely depends something
i think it begins with a w um anyway it
it's uh 1800s
film or tv show
i don't know i couldn't i couldn't tell
you if i haven't i've seen it um but
anyway it's about um
victorian um
lesbian that has that it's a true story
about a victory yeah of course i did yes
i know you yeah yeah and that was kind
of cool especially the whenever it
breaks the fourth frame you know uh the
character does yeah
surrounding woman that's starting that
is um she's in lots of cop shows over
here she just she just oh
right let's call it ex i don't know
about you stormy
but i'm i'm getting a sore throat
minutes now
yeah you've kept me up for four
congratulations to me this may be no
it's not a record i think it kept you on
a full
hour and five minutes late
yeah we've done two hour videos in here
before
um but hey lots of good because i like
to do little snippet videos when i've
got time right and we've talked about
load so i don't have to try to remember
what we've talked about to find it so i
can snip it so i can do shorter videos
but we have a clip channel yet do you
have a clip channel i should do one
shouldn't i just
but i tend to do the clips on here
because um people either like and then
you guys tell me if you think some
people like the long video and they like
they'll sit with us for bloody two hours
and but other people they don't want to
stick more than 10 minutes
so
i make it i try to make it clear that
it's it's a clip but well what you
should do is you know put the clip on
this channel and then also duplicate it
over on a clip channel
sidetrack clips maybe i'll do that if
i've got time maybe i'll do a sidetrack
clips and then i can go through
all the videos and do clips from all of
my videos
so like 130 something videos i'd have to
go through ah somebody else wanted my
problem dude i'm not your editor sorry
i'm not supposed to do it for me i'll
split the profits with you
my channel i just
this uh let me just paint my latest uh
uh cy works video it's math versus
culture
it's like why are all the the
mathematicians or european white guys
you know and i
know where pythagoran's theorem was in
use
documented on egyptian papyrus a
thousand years before the birth of
pythagoras or whatever
so that was my rant and there's a really
good book the crest of the peacock that
talks a lot about
you know arabic numerals where there's
all these memes floating around people
go up and take um
they take polls of americans is
do you really want your child to learn
arabic numerals in school
they go oh god no oh god no no
two-thirds of americans do not want
liberal teachers teaching arabic
numerals in school
which is what we use
zero through
nine those are
actually they're hindu arabic numerals
but you know
of all this
so that's what it's about please go
click on it enjoy it comment share your
outreach it sounds massively exciting
um i think anything that is based around
maths
is just oh mate it's that oh i actually
get a little bit excited physically
you know like in my pants thinking about
it
well then you should watch this over and
over and over oh man i can't wait
it's like um
i i will
watch all of your videos sir as you well
know and i leave comments about them you
do um um but but i i will see let's see
but please go and share on the sidetrack
group
we love we love you stormy and i'm
certain the video about i feel like i'm
digging myself into a hole here because
i don't understand maths so
well i really i just you know i just you
know used pythagoras theorem as the
thing that
even was credited to pythagoras it was
in use thousand years before he ever we
give him credit for that and there's two
papyruses
you know that are from egypt and talking
about you know really complex
mathematical formulas but yet one's
called the berlin papyrus
6619 and he owns called the moscow
proprietors there's no one from moscow
that developed this there's no one from
berlin that berlin wasn't even a town
when this thing was written
but let's not credit the egyptians
okay let's give him something yeah
right we're good at racism are we i i do
finally find that we can see we keep
saying that we discovered america
because we discovered america for us
the vikings discovered it before that
and obviously there was a whole
population of people live there but we
say that chris mcconvis discovered
american because
columbus got here man there's already
millions of people here with
his history going back ten thousand
years
with a country that is already massively
populated we've got [ __ ] or
we've got rock carvings out here in the
desert that's 8 000 years old
yeah
gotta love it
but anyway that's a completely different
conversation and now you've got me
five minutes over the hour so
on my own thing sanctuary was a great
channel by the way it was a great
episode right um apparently i am doing
eclipse video two or three people have
said in the clips that i need to so
thanks more work great um i need to quit
my job i need to get my wife to get a
better job so she i can live off her
so i could just focus on youtube
that's the dream
guys thank you for every cpm
if you don't mind me asking what sir
what's your average cpm how what are
people paying per thousand um
impressions one second i'll tell you
is this something i should keep private
oh i don't know
my average cpm ah
or no my rpm is 4.96 my
playback based cpm is 10 pounds 18. so
about
13 or 14 dollars sometimes
i tell you what i did go through i had a
an alert last week from youtube saying
i've just gone through a million views
and i'm not saying
well yeah you're much more popular than
i am
it's because i'm nicer
i'm trying to get 20 100 subscribers and
i think you you're way past you're going
to get one of those plaques pretty soon
i'm because i'm pretty
that's what it is it's because i'm just
so damn pretty
i don't think so i i had my favorite
comment a little while ago was
man this guy's got a face for radio
thank you you gotta love your fans you
bothered writing that
um you bothered writing that but that's
great but yeah now this this channel is
going great and we've got some amazing
subscribers and they always got comments
and they always point out when i make a
mistake on a video thanks for that and
a little more comment than i'd like
um but you know i haven't made any
really bad mistake for a while so that's
good um
i did
yeah i need to work on that i need to
make some mistakes i did say that um i'm
going to start putting a deliberate
mistake in every video just to try to
cover up the fact that then when i do
make a mistake it's like oh you know
that was a deliberate one oh you know
um but it didn't work nobody believes me
um
have a lovely lovely evening stormy
everybody in the comments as usual
you've been amazing i've tried to keep
up reading it but i gave up a little
while ago
um
stormy is from california um it's a
storm if you want to give out your
address quickly before we come out i'm
joking um
sci-fi family hit that like button
supreme lord is on it today
and you shall share the video wherever
the hell you like tell your friends um
another american is joining us next week
we're having an open chat we're just
talking about whatever the hell we like
um and we will we will see where that
takes us
um but he's a very interesting chap and
i think i'm going to not say much
because i think you guys will get on
like a house on fire because he's works
in the industry and things and
so yeah we'll see how that goes we'll
talk [ __ ] about you
yeah yeah i'll just sit in the corner
we don't even need you on screen
let's get drunk
okay
see you later guys all right see ya bye
[Music]
you